alright so I'm going to attempt to not
perpetrate my pontifications into
perpetuity so i will talk for a couple
of more seconds about my least favorite
subject with such myself so as he said
i'm taking for my research background
and machine learning data mining etc as
you can read they're applying scalable
data platforms software engineering
stochastic models to be able to figure
out how do users interact with systems
how do systems interact with other
systems and how can we build models that
that we can basically build an
understanding of how these things
actually work together towards a more
secure environment so for the past six
months I've worked with Cisco on the
advanced threat analytics with a tool
called open stock and the main idea here
is we're standing up a full stack of
hardware inside of our customers
networks that is able to take in 1.5
million events per second run it through
a number of different models and
basically build a a threat risk
portfolio for the network and we have
some really smart folks that on the back
end look at our machine learning
algorithms the outputs of that and build
a report for individual threats that we
send up to a customer so specifically my
team which is the data science team we
have three main roles one is to research
threats models and algorithms to to
prototype these in a safe environment
using data that we've gotten from our
customers and three to weaponize this
which is to take it and put it into
production in a way such that we make
our our customers networks a little bit
more secure so we like to think of
ourselves as the good guys a lot of this
stuff is really really scary if you
think about it you know we we have all
this information and we have all these
people that have access to the
information how do we make this safe how
do we keep from turning into
brother whenever we're talking about
these things so most of you guys will
and ladies will actually recognize this
is Conway's data science Venn diagram
and this is the the classical way that
people look at how data scientists in
analytics professionals view of the
world and his purported danger zone was
somewhere in between hacking skills and
substantive expertise after the NSA
prism came out someone came along and
added an extra dimension of evil and if
anybody in the NSA's in the room I'm
sorry this is not my my picture so you
know don't come to my house later in you
know they put this this on here so why
everybody's looking to see where where
am I on this diagram where is everybody
I know on this diagram just just think
about we have this this in the United
States we have this this set of
organizations that has access to all of
this information what are they wanting
to do with it and then on the on the
flip side the the guy who steals our
identity online also may have access to
that information because you know he's
in that new danger zone so this is frank
gunn word from house of cards he's my
one of my favorite TV villains this this
is my favorite representation of Big
Brother right so this is this is the guy
that says you know I know what's best
for you I'm going to do whatever the
heck I want and you know you guys are
left out to lunch so that's one side of
the coin the other side is we've got
these you know these these freedom
fighters whatever you want to call them
anarchists crazy people that feel like
they have they have the right to access
anything in any of these systems as well
so the American people are like okay so
what's going on we've got these we got
these two sides of the same coin
everybody wants our data everybody wants
to be able to capitalize on it and we're
stuck in between these two two extremes
we got Big Brother on one side this
dystopian future and then on the other
side we've got absolute data anarchy and
it seems like everybody is wanting to
take their own approach on this and the
American people are like
I don't really care what's going on I
just want to sit on my couch in my
mickey mouse pajamas eating ice cream
and watching fringe three runs without
caring who's going to be watching me
through my xbox kinect camera so
everybody has their own approach to this
and everybody says okay we're going to
make our data private and what you wind
up with is a whole bunch of people doing
things in completely different ways and
missing the big picture so they all
reinvent the wheel and this lack of
communication is systemic basically it
brings to mind this this idea that comes
from reiation tradition which is a bunch
of visually impaired books are tasked
with describing what is an elephant
based on their senses so one guy feels a
trunk and he's like okay it's like a
it's like a tree branch another one
feels the legs and it's like now it's
kind of like a column another one pills
his tummy is like guys you guys are
idiots those things a wall and so on and
so forth they all have their own
different perspectives and it's not
necessarily that any of them are wrong
it's just that you have to take a
holistic view everybody has their own
view and we have to combine these
together in order to get some some good
information on what the threat is that
we're all actually combating so the way
that I've looked at this for the past
few years while doing my research I
actually had to come to an epiphany it
says basically we are as researchers we
have access to all of this information
we have the IRB the institutional review
board with my graduate school but also
as professionals we are charged with
being stewards of this data we are
charged with making sure that it doesn't
get input into the wrong hands and if we
were creating methods around this how do
we do this in a way such that we are not
compromising the American Way of life so
this presentation is part positioned
paper if it was a and his part survey so
I'm gonna have a little bit of something
for everybody so let me start off with a
little bit of a survey and the question
I want to answer with this is how do we
anonymize data without losing the
multivariate statistical significant
significance of the data which means how
do we take a set of input data transform
it in a way such that if we run our
algorithms on it will still be able to
get the same insights but if that data
is compromised we're not compromising
individual user privacy so there are two
main concepts here there's anonymization
and summarization and I'll go through
summarization first so the idea here is
you taking an input set of data you run
it through a model pipeline in the idea
the these models are set up specifically
so they can summarize the data in
whatever way that they do best so you
can set up say regression you can set up
decision trees etc and your idea is to
build up a series of models that
describe the data in the best way that
you think so instead of having the
actual data what you have now is a set
of models that you think describe the
data but you're not able to actually do
anything with the data itself so you
bring it into a lab and use the models
to regenerate it and then you can draw
your analysis based on that the problem
here is that your output is only going
to be as good as what you got out of the
model right so if you try to do any sort
of analytics on the information that has
already been summarized you are
basically just saying what the model did
and that's not particularly useful so
the main concept that I will be trying
to get across to you is anonymous ation
where you run your data through a
transformation pipeline you have input
data d and you pull out transform data d
prime and you move it into your lab for
analysis so one of the most simple ways
that I can actually communicate how
generalization works is you have two
clusters of points on a two-dimensional
Cartesian point plane and instead of
actually pulling in these 40 points and
sending them to somebody to do the
analysis you say okay I can have two
points here that represent the two
different clusters and say there's a
range of data
around those clusters and then just send
the two points and we can regenerate
points that are in that same range so
the idea here is if it has webbed feet
like a duck has a bill like a duck eats
the same things as a duck it's probably
a platypus so you know you meant to say
platypus so the I the idea is if we're
if we're trying to summarize this data
you don't know what you're going to get
out and it might have a completely
different view of it so some classical
ways of doing an anonymous ation not
summarization I'm sure you're all
familiar with the the tried and true
black marker that goes through this
isn't really scalable in terms of doing
data analytics right so you get a small
percentage of information this is this
is the same thing as going through your
data set and removing columns or
removing rows or removing specific
categories about individual rows so it's
not very good whenever the time comes to
do analytics because you get basically
prepositions and you know some basic
mountains and and it's not it's not
particularly useful another one which is
which is pretty interesting is
encryption I'm not going to go through
specifics of various encryption
algorithms just the the main idea is you
take in a key you take in some plain
text and then you run it through an
encryption method transmit it to someone
else and they do an inverse process on
it to get the plain text back the idea
is if somebody's in the middle they have
access to the ciphertext but they do not
have access to the plain text without
the key and in some cases the algorithm
so there is some some recent research
that came out in one of the I Triple E
magazines about being able to do some
basic mathematical operations on
encrypted data which was pretty
outstanding to me but the problem with
that is even even if you're able to do
those basement at basic mathematical
operations like summation multiplication
they said that the the methods run about
a million times slower than if you were
trying to do it just with beer machine
code which again isn't particularly
useful and then the encrypted data isn't
particularly useful as well for doing
analytics
another classical method is
steganography which is basically your
needle in a haystack you take
information such as this right here say
this is the message we want to transmit
you mix it with the the regular picture
on the on the left and then you get an
output picture right here basically it's
you're hiding a needle inside of a
haystack and you're hoping that nobody
is going to be able to figure out what
where the needle is and that is a basic
the basic idea behind hiding data so
that's how some people are able to get
around privacy laws nowadays is to hide
information like this again not
particularly useful for analytics and
another method is perturbing your data
which is basically introducing
randomization so if you have an original
set of data that's linear in nature you
can you can either insert or remove
individual points along the line and the
idea is that again you're trying to
summarize or you're hoping that by
perturbing the data you're not going to
change it in a way that influences the
message that your data is trying to
communicate however as you can see here
the trend line of this perturb data is
not in I mean it's kind of close but
it's not exactly representing the the
same data so there are way too many
things to try to get through with this
so here are some some some other methods
that come from both of these schools of
thought about how we can actually
anonymize and summarize data for
analysis without actually compromising
user privacy so the main thing I want to
talk to you about is substitution so
this is this is actually based on some
you know one of the earliest methods of
encryption which is the substitution
cipher and this has problems if you know
about the netflix data prize they were
able to take some anonymize netflix data
compare it to information that was on
IMDb which is an internet internet movie
rating website and be able to determine
based on the correlation between those
sets of ratings individual users on IMDb
with the users on Netflix so it has some
problems but our idea is that it's
moving from point A to point B inside of
our lab it's encrypted and once it gets
into our lab we have set of trusted
users that half of them have clearances
so we're assuming that they are going to
be somewhat trustworthy and we can talk
about the broader set of privacy issues
in our roundtable later so substitution
mapping how can we use substitution to
anonymize data okay I'm glad I asked so
the the idea here is basically you can
there are two different ways of doing
this there's the kind of a key value
mapping where you take in categories so
this would be say a five couple that
we're looking at with network data you
run it through this substitution map and
says okay class IP this is the input
value let's substitute it with this
output value a another IP that's coming
through we're going to substitute to it
with B and port we're just going to
select a randomly a random number as a
port as well so the idea is you keep a
running set of these these things and
then you're able to produce data prime
which looks like this and you have your
you have your own on lies data set if
you do this repeatedly for each
individual road so the idea is if you
discover a pattern that's in data prime
then you can then send the data Prime
back through the substitution map to
your customer and say hey we discovered
something interesting going on with
these guys we don't know what the data
is go investigate further you have the
actual data and this is it's similar to
it's similar to having to you know for
better or worse fill out forms and go
through specific legal pathways to get
access to data if you're in law
enforcement so the other way is so
that's that's how you would do it for
categorical data for numerical data you
can do something with units where
basically you take a scaling value for
the same unit you do multiplications and
then you get the same idea data prime
you do an analysis on it send it back
through and then
voila so how does this or why does this
work let's look at some fictitious seals
for a specific car dealer for fiscal
year 2014 you can see corolla's doing
some you know it's slipping down but
overall cotton constant Wrangler it's
it's got this this log one of the
logarithmic type deviation and then
f-150s are going down etc etc you see
there's basic pattern here so if we go
through the anonymization process you'll
see that the both the scale of those
numbers change as well as the products
themselves you can still see the same
patterns you can still still make the
same insight from that data but you
don't know exactly what these things are
without a priori information or
comparing it to another set of data that
you might have access to so side by side
you can see it's essentially the same
thing like I said just the units and the
the names are changed so that's for cars
but if we look at something like about
individual users we're talking about
privacy right so for individual folks
you can say okay what we're going to
evaluate the folks that are putting
things out there it looks like dr.
Wolfram's putting out a lot of papers
and Albert Einstein's not really
publishing too much in 2014 big surprise
so once again you run it through the
anonymization process etc so this is
this is pretty cool from a conceptual
perspective because you're able to
you're able to do the same sort of
analytics without actually compromising
user privacy great okay so what happens
when we're wanting to do this on 1.5
million events per second per customer
and over a number of different data
centers per each customer that's where
things get a little bit interesting so
how do we make this scalable right so
the main idea here is so the original
process is you take your data run it
through the scalable substitution matrix
or mapping like it just said and then
you get your data prime to make it
scalable you divide your data into a
number of different patterns here you
run it through an equal number of maps
and then you aggregate it at the end and
get a data Prime so this is good but
what happens whenever you see
information on one map and it doesn't
necessarily it well you see information
on one map and you also see the same
information on another map and you
generate two different keys for each one
of those maps then you have some some
some overlap there which is a problem so
how do we deal with this we deal with it
using the Pacus algorithm which sits on
side of neo4j and as well as patchy
zookeeper so the main idea here is that
we want to maintain data consistency
with these internal data structures that
we're actually using so how do we do
that with the packs without rhythm and
what can we do with anonymous data we
can do your you know we can run the
gamut of models on it right we can throw
your basic exploratory analysis
clustering decision trees etc I'm not
going to read that to you but yeah you
can do the same sorts of analysis the
unit will shift you'll get a little
different set of information from it but
you can still the same see the same
patterns and if you see something
interesting you can run it back through
the map or you can send it to your
customer who can run it through the map
and say okay these are the insights for
this specific thing that way you're not
compromising individual user privacy
you're not compromising the data itself
with the process of getting the insights
from it so how do we turn this into
something that we can use so Francisco
the traditional way is for all of our
customers we have a TA that stands up we
do our process of research weaponize and
deploy the models push it back up into a
TA and then each individual customer as
a boutique set of algorithms that they
use to describe their data and to
predict threats and now in a
multi-tenant idea is we would take the
information anonymize it pull it up into
a pullet pull the anonymized encrypted
data up into our data store where we can
do analysis on it and then we can share
that information out to all of the
customers
because it's anonymized or we can just
share the models out to the customers
that way when we're talking about people
are not communicating we can have all of
our customers be able to benefit from
our understanding of the threat
landscape for each individual customer
and that's kind of an analog to what I
want to get across with this thing is
even for us this is this is our way of
doing it but the question that I really
want to get to you folks is how can we
communicate better as an industry about
privacy how can we communicate and
better as an industry about the threats
that are out there and how can we do
that in a way that is useful for our
customers useful for our users and
doesn't compromise privacy how do we
balance being big brother with the the
anarchy and chaos of you know just open
everything so another story this comes
from Aesop fables the the there's this
guy and he has I think the wording is he
has a particularly contentious brood of
children and they can't seem to get
along so he says here's bundle istics I
want you guys to break them so they all
come on they try to break the via the
bundle of sticks and he says okay unbind
them I'm sure must've heard of the store
and buying this the the sticks and try
to break them individually so at that
point they're able to obviously easily
go and break the sticks so the idea here
is there is unity and strength there is
unity so in unity there is strength when
we strike that reverse it and through
the process of us working together
toward this problem and trying to find
solutions for it hopefully we can make
the world a better place and we can all
sit on our couch and watch Netflix
without a you know wearing who's
watching watching us so some further
reading i'll post the slides up later
here's a whole bunch of information
about what we do as well as the the
background research